[Music]
this started out as a protest against
the policing bill in parliament
but it quickly turned into a march
against the tactics used by officers
to break up saturday night's vigil in
memory of sarah everard
by the time it ended the government had
doubled the size of its safer streets
fund
aimed at improving lighting and cctv
the prime minister really really wanted
to show that we are listening and that
we want to act
to help women feel safe in our streets
which is why this investment
will go on very practical measures like
increasing better lighting
more cctv to try to give people that
confidence
that we really really want to instill
after last week's terribly terribly sad
events
at clapham common more and more tributes
have been left at the bandstand
just a few streets away from where sarah
was abducted
we don't just need legislation we need a
kind of a uk-wide a worldwide
culture change so much needs to change
the way that
we view women and the way that we
respect women or
the way that we don't respect women the
prime minister says he wants to drive
out violence against women and girls and
will bring in landmark legislation
to toughen sentences and put more police
on the streets
saturday night's events in fapum are now
the subject of a review by the police
inspectorate
ordered by the home secretary who has
also urged the public not to attend
any further vigils because of the
pandemic
wayne cousins the 48 year old police
officer charged with sarah everard's
murder
will appear at the old bailly later
today ender brady sky news